one of the hardest parts of adulting i
love this new term adulting um is
choosing the perfect place to live and
settle down and call a home i think i
was talking about there are chapters in
life and
one of mine is the decision to move from
los angeles to new york which was very
unsettling but i knew that it was the
right thing to do it was what my
daughters needed and it just they're my
north star so i made the bold move i
took the leap i've ended up finding
tremendous happiness and there are just
times in our lives where something
happens that was unexpected and we've
just got to take that leap and our next
guest took her own leap of faith packed
up all of her belongings and moved from
chicago illinois to the big apple
all by herself
hi i'm moyo and i just fulfilled my
dream of moving to new york city after
finishing my master's degree i moved
back into my parents home in chicago and
even though i was so happy i knew i
needed to get out and live my life so i
decided to come to new york i was very
set on fall 2020 that was the goal but
we all know what happened um the
pandemic but i'm here now 2021.
since i don't have a lot of space all of
the shoes handbags and clothing that i'm
gonna be buying don't tell my dad um i'm
gonna have to find ways to be organized
in my my room so here's my room and it
was just a bed and dresser when i came
in
so i'm excited to fill it up and make it
very homey i just love that it's an open
like canvas similar to my experience in
new york it's an open opportunity right
a city of opportunity so i'm super
excited to decorate it and make it my
home
[Applause]
i have been thinking about you a lot it
is really nice to meet you in person
meet you um
why did you want to come to new york
i've just always wanted to live in new
york like it's it's kind of crazy
um it's like an addiction i just i love
the city it's like a city of
opportunities the diversity the people
the fashion
the food i just love it you are so
beautiful inside and out and um i know
you um think that you're just here so
that we could recommend some uh new york
places that you need to hit
but i couldn't help
myself i got all up involved in your
design
and your place and um i hope you don't
mind if we now surprise you by throwing
into a segment called designed by drew
[Applause]
so
that is your space yes um i did want to
put a brand new room um together for you
it's behind these doors
so god here we go open those doors
[Applause]
can i come in come
[Applause]
everything in here if you like it no i
like it i love it coming to your house
and will be installed thank you
i like it a lot really no i do i really
love the color but i love the clean look
nerve-wracking design i like it
before you really get to know someone um
but i did find out some of your likes
and dislikes now i'll take you through a
couple of reasons of why i chose certain
things um first of all um
i loved the pops of color with like you
know um
pop art yes i wanted colored pillows but
if you are not feeling as bold that day
you just remove the pillows and you have
a gorgeous white
bed
that is alluring and calming and by the
way when you have these spaces move
stuff around you know
edit change like all of a sudden this
completely went from a lot of color to a
lot less color yeah um i chose this
because there is a real discrepancy out
there in the marketplace of
basically couches that can go at the
foot of your bed nobody wants to sit on
a bench you don't i'm sorry you know
what it becomes your your your outdoor
closet that's true but if you can
actually be able to sit comfortably
then your room can become a social hub
and you're not sitting on your bed
that's true but most couches are
honestly way too high to be at the foot
of your bed and this is a problem so my
suggestion is you actually trim the legs
and lower them but a couch at the end of
the bed opens it up to being able to
hang out in there right
um and um
then when it comes to lamps my cardinal
rule is
don't go with a metal shade or an opaque
shade you will not get light from those
you'll get up and down light
but you i am obsessed with shades that
actually let the whole light glow yeah
and don't get me started on can lighting
whoever invented can lighting i'd like
to meet you in a dark alley
um
by the way no woman looks good in canned
lighting
do you ever go in the bathroom and
you're like oh my god
where did all my self-confidence go
can lighting
because overhead lighting makes you look
like you're starring in your own
personal mug shot
so
i also love this headboard and chose it
because i thought it was unique in the
marketplace because it goes behind the
nightstands and if you notice most
headboards will be cut off right here
okay well here you go it's all coming
with you okay
thank you
and um thank you thank you
i really appreciate your time
[Music]
you